la transición del gobierno de trump al
de vaivén no podía comenzar sin la
administración general de servicios y
finalmente el lunes la entidad le dio
luz verde al nuevo mandato emily marfil
la líder de la entidad se había negado a
reconocer la victoria de bait y sin su
aprobación la institución que suministra
los fondos para las oficinas federales
no le transferiría el dinero necesario
para hacer el empalme algo que el
presidente electo esperaba desde que se
confirmó su victoria tras la presión del
congreso y la certificación en michigan
que ratificó la victoria en ese estado
para bailén la administración general de
servicios tomó el paso definitivo he
determinado que puede acceder a los
recursos y servicios post elecciones
descritos en la sección 3 de la ley si
lo solicita la entidad aclaró que tomó
la decisión de manera independiente al
poco tiempo de su carta del presidente
publicó en su cuenta de 'twitter' que le
recomendaba a marfil a su oficina hacer
lo que fuera necesario para la
transición así por primera vez
trump se mostró dispuesto a abandonar la
casa oval y creo que prevaleceremos sin
embargo el mejor interés de nuestro país
recomiendo que emily y su equipo hagan
lo que sea necesario con respecto a los
protocolos iniciales y le he dicho a mi
equipo que haga lo mismo
con el aval de la administración general
de servicios ahora bailén y la
vicepresidenta electa kamala harris ya
tendrán fondos federales y oficinas para
hacer el empalme con el gobierno de
trump incluso recibirán los informes
periódicos de seguridad nacional que
también recibe el presidente el equipo
de bailén ya anunció que la transición
comenzará con los funcionarios federales
que manejan la pandemia y con los de
seguridad nacional